it's 7:00 a.m. at the strait of messina
it looks just like a normal stretch of
the Mediterranean except for the boats
with the towering masts with people
perched atop someone also appears to be
floating across the water standing on an
arms stretched far out in front these
vessels are called feluccas fishing
boats invented in ancient greece which
have been specially redesigned for
hunting swordfish the people up in the
lookouts 27 metres above sea level
navigate the boat and spot prey climbing
up there's difficult and dangerous with
no safety harness the harpoonist makes
his way to the front of the boom once
the helmsman is in place the villa Ko
can begin the hunt for highly coveted
swordfish
Josep ax is a veteran swordfish hunter
here on the strait of messina the crew
that he's joining today are all friends
of his and he's expecting a good haul
the fish come really near to the coast
at the moment it's the right season now
it's just up to the helmsman and the
harpoonist
to do their jobs today each felucca has
a hunting ground covering to see miles
the trick is to steer so that the
harpoonist is situated directly above
the fish they swim here in shallow
coastal waters just below the surface
but only for a minute or two
so the harpoonist has to strike quickly
before they vanish zipper has gone out
with this particular fishing boat many
times she's called Patriota secondo
Marco Giovanni and Camilla will be in
the control tower keeping lookout for
several hours the final preparations are
underway down on deck such as fitting
the ropes for the harpoon
and then it's all go the harpoonist a
plea named Fortunato was certainly
fortunate this time there was no escape
for the fish the five prong harpoon
plunged deep into the swordfish this is
an extremely dangerous moment for the
men the creature battles to defend
itself and the spirit of a swordfish can
cause serious injury it takes all our
collective strength to restrain the fish
otherwise it can jump we do this until
it loses all its energy and dies
Fortunato is already back at his post he
strikes another fish a few hundred
metres from the beach but up on the
lookout they're not happy the swordfish
hasn't been struck properly and it's
pulling on the line with all its
strength it's going to take a long time
to reel it in the animal tries to dive
back down to drain the fish's strings
you have to keep releasing the line and
then reading it back in this one is
refusing to give up the fight
but in the end the men's brute strength
wins through
the swordfish is marked so it's cleared
the fish market that it was caught by
hand and not fished commercially we
don't fish we hunt there's no net and no
hooks just a harpoon when you see the
fish you need to have lightning fast
reactions just like a hunter with a
shotgun
Fortunato isn't always lucky
today there are fish but for many years
the number of swordfish in the
Mediterranean has been declining forcing
many people in Messina to give up
traditional hunting long ago
woman see what they made on that bucket
how can a fishing boat like this with a
crew make money the costs are often
higher than the return it's really not
worth the effort anymore if there's no
profit they used to be dozens of
feluccas plying the strait between
Sicily and Calabria during the summer
hunting season now most of them are
sitting on dry land including Jews Epis
felucca Giuseppe didn't stand a chance
against the trawlers with their
commercial fishing equipment swordfish
hunters like him have no Lobby in Italy
anymore Giuseppe wants to scrap his boat
now it means he'll get a payout from the
government in Rome it's of little
interest to them but this custom in the
Mediterranean is dying out
swordfish hunting has been providing
food and work for centuries as well as a
sense of tradition and identity which is
now sadly under threat here in Messina